hey everybody and we were back here at
the samsung stage at e3 2014 again I'm
your host John McGuinness and I am
incredibly excited to be joined by our
next guest it is none other than Hideo
Kojima the creator of the Metal Gear
Solid franchise kojima-san thank you so
much for joining us and of course we've
got a translator Ken on stage as well to
help out Kojima son with the release of
the new trailer this week it really
gives us a lot more insight into the
development of snake as a character and
you know as the creator of snake you're
definitely the driving force between his
evolution throughout the series so for
you
I'm curious what's it like you know
taking snake as a character from naked
snake to where we see him with this most
recent trailer going from you know a
good guy to a very troubled character
with very different motivations stories
begin at the SkyDome all today good to
know our terrific appreciation one cara
su-34 xbox one tyranny technology no
sink a totem Oni Ezra at Ceres a toast a
ishani technology toss in comedy news
initially it was a choice ticked up to a
subduction our character nom de Pury got
a keen eye k2 mascota
nano de sao paulo machado stay a mike a
snake oh right they do do you top erotic
story wise precise the estimation
however snake the whole concept of snake
is a character has been evolving it's a
very unique character because he has his
it has been evolving along with the
players through
Metal Gear Solid 1 on PlayStation along
all time has been developing with the
player so snake has evolved in a very
unique way and each time I try to make
him add a new character a different
character try to keep him evolving is it
difficult for you to kind of have him
turn from the from this good guy to this
to this bad guy as time goes on
compared to no it was the regular at
after him we need the big personality no
user is my Steven all day MA he know
that tominaga hakuna never to Corregidor
you could I know my dad straight every
time you got it I got a new disc a demo
game Priya gosh I think oh I pray a
gamma given day a so no a you what
capita creatively Makara pokhara an
awkward with a Sergey who neva and not
took I can I know the suppose music's
catacomb Chi user know me as I'm on up
talk like watashi de zuñiga acoustical
ducky the more even more a snake you
know
hakuna cotton through salsa oh hey kemo
joke - aren't you can achieve a morte a
plastic we all now saw you cause Oh a
kinesthetic optimist it is indeed a very
complex process because the player
always has controlled this character
there is make that is a cure that is a
good guy and if officer you tell them
are you gonna be controlling the bag are
you gonna be you're gonna be the villain
you know this happens of any movies
we're just like Darth Vader you just
become officer on the bad guy and it's
not that difficult Howard in games it's
much more complex because you're showing
the player first you're controlling the
good guy the hero and all of a sudden a
now you're the bad guy built the people
probably won't be on like this so it's a
very delicate balance where you have to
first I love the player to understand
why the character is going through all
these phase through this transition from
going to being a good guy to the villain
and also I want to make sure that the
people as long as they endure they
understand this and also have this dough
morale where they don't want to take to
go to that dark side with the bad side
but on the on the other side understand
why he's doing this and that's up to
certain point wanting to actually
execute all these actions because they
they know why he's doing this
ye ask a cadiz worry
Tokoro niku no automatic a the more
sorry more edgy you much thank you so so
gonna synchro adenosine koto praiano
synchro mascot a Sinagra outta heaven
because in America they all got on the
tight ends that were odd - oh no
everyone knows how this game will end
because ghosts are behaving and that's
game
everyone knows this but I'm trying to
I'm trying a Walter why desk approach
from Breaking Bad where people watching
this art don't want the character to go
there but at the same time they just
want to see wanna see the structure go
through all all of this and it's
definitely hard but I want players to
understand and go along synchronize
Empire empathize with the character
that's the big boss point to outer Haven
I'm becoming who he ended up becoming
being okay now we do have a little bit
of b-roll that we're gonna roll right
now as we continue this interview here
we're not going to jump into the
specifics of the gameplay we don't want
to spoil too many things but we'll
continue our discussion of the you know
the franchise as a whole with the
phantom pain we see snake moving from
his days of running the I'm gonna do my
best French voice here the military
assault frontier as he moves from that
to the Diamond Dogs and it really looks
like you know looking at those two
groups looking forward to the future
with Foxhound these big groups and
organizations are a big theme in the
series and I'm just wondering what is it
about those big groups and these
powerful organizations that appeal to
you as a storyteller what what function
do they serve when you're trying to
build a narrative
my amigo all my steps are no it devane's
it in or out there so no matter no it
means you know hoax and you're dead and
all Marinho on a map - ain't no size you
know any good a veto on this key the
more mine anymore mother took us to sum
up their touch key a hawk I said am i
this forum for this game is you know
this a you have this bigger organization
and it breaks down it falls down it is
it is destroyed
so there's revenge because of this no
much to eat study god but joke in a big
50 who don't own I walk in and let's get
them or I will shoot them the hi little
sonu sood am total money a drinker gotta
say they could to category back then so
you know act I know there a scenario so
skewed scriptura was its put a plastic
naqudae so skill to you knock up a snake
la la
aqua Neos stay good to know Malcolm
cassano big emo to me a customer the
other aspect that I want to portray here
is that as you mentioned sneak creates
an organization and it breaks down and
one one person is an organization is not
too hard to see that that person is
changed by this organization even if
that person create this survivor train
how he creates one organization and then
this is destroyed or destroys it and
then it goes on other organization this
metamorphose is sort of snake as a
character how it goes is changing by
being an organization and by being a
creating and destroying an organization
how great i want to portray that that's
one of the themes of this game as well
now if you could compare the MSF and the
Diamond Dogs specifically what do you
think is different about these because
snake has evolved a lot over time how
does his new personality what he's
experienced affect this organization
my quest is a kid or a missive ikazuchi
I get there they're so good and I come
out to meet there the kid only not tumba
Skidmore yeah personal scatter suit you
to go to America like oogie oogie to
cotton and a solid a slicker kako mo
table that is low came to cook a Marino
cenk Uygur are given a socio Cohen sorry
toboggan I'm there
mou ichido diam on the docks of school
this kid a walk-on as he could over stop
and I stuck with nine or their so-called
kinda gonna bitten all succeed on their
atrophy egg mama gravis toka throats
grow to salute my Congress on O Hara see
so I cannot go into non into too much
detail about this but the owner ping is
so sneak created MSM it was going well
it was working perfectly well and but
whenever the iron organization becomes
too powerful it is natural that is that
it is attacked by other organizations
that that's what happened with them
except actually appointed in order to
for deterrence the MSF had a nuclear
weapon I didn't Deanna got destroyed and
it got broken down because it became a
quite a powerful organization now in
this in this time this time snake is
creating a similar organization but of
course snake is thinking he's thinking I
don't want the same thing to happen so
he has a different theory a different
approach a different structure to when
you screen them on dogs and that is
exactly what I want to portray in this
game P so car there ma are Musti oh no
tameni
so Scott's good done this get off take a
tahini gustaría my stack a dog come
caboose sternotomy a rock they're given
no she would have means of scotland a
so-called tenth ulema another big
difference is MSF was creating peace
walker warpath for this for this girl
that is best
that's the whole reason this already
station was created however Diamond Dogs
is a very different thing is has very
different reasons as they're very
different motifs and because of that
alone there is
they are very different and they turn up
being very different organizations okay
now it's you know it's not all big
organizations in the Metal Gear Solid
franchise it's also about personal
relationships between different
characters you know in in the phantom
pain I think we're going to learn a bit
about the relationship between snake and
Ocelot but when you're working on these
relationships in this story you know
what what is it that you're trying to
contribute to the overall story like how
do you look at what a relations what
role a relation sorry a relationship can
serve and what do you stay tight a
message oh mother there
sorry Oh economy started to talk all day
a character Ojai to stay hey Sonu Nigam
can get started go to the capacity
control you must see so high K or your
model state a photo to Sydney character
high to stay there so no ten top ten Oh
Jimbo Jimbo's Oh economist undercut the
re where you can take in our user that
we need oh you should hold a star game
with this dialogue a story dead fan of
inventory 750 no kangaroo hello mom
monogatari toe game of screwed up to you
that I wanna portrayed Nora about there
is always a theme a message that I want
to keep through my games so that's the
core and based on that I've made a pink
of the characters I placed my characters
in a way that they are able to relate
this message that I want to tell this
theme or I sit down on pink whether it's
it is better to use for example if I
place these structures like this and
they have this kind of relationship they
will be able to get that message out
there or maybe sometimes it's a message
egg
give out through gameplay or through the
characters background or whatnot so in
the Korra there's some a theme and
message that I want to relate and based
on its own sometimes the best way to
communicate this is through the
relationship between characters yeah I
mean one of the it always seems like
theme is something that's very important
with the franchise as you say and that
doesn't just apply to the characters it
also applies to the gameplay as well how
do you how do you how would you describe
the process of thinking of what theme
that you want to portray in a game and
making sure that the gameplay works well
with that something like mother base and
peace walker that customization that
responsibility an overall so then [ __ ]
you can so to get scooted a meter run
the 100 this I go to but our goal a good
a teeny but I'm frequently asked for
every time I make a game I don't think
of what will happen after so what our
working when I was working medical one
and what I was going to be the last game
I was working on my gear to that dev
will be last game and as usual this time
I also thinking this is this will be my
very last game so when I'm thinking this
is my very last game and
I'm not gonna be able to do anything
afterwards I try to put everything and
want to make sure that what I wanted
communicate is there it's critical dis
get them all so not too much okay hang
on security token you put on appletinis
yes or no eternal Kotoko token great
opportunity ba yah ding ding you know
what am i there it is you got a mother
tongue yeah it is in no tane I don't got
a key mammy Moutinho ah don't have to
you know come get the degrees they
adjust to their me must avenge myself
day peace okey-dokey - you know tight on
this ghetto more but 5 of screwed up in
a jar
yo I gotta get all the same so no mean
ammonia no captain gudnayev pari issued
a soon and who casino range the whole
saga a games I know Monica you know I
know a director photo ma gain another
tamaño de são leopoldo game no system at
all
story no system Eirik on there in a game
negara replace the Murano glass or a
total 4d customer out - so it's cricket
or thing example from earlier one the
team was gene because I thought did the
genetics the genes were the most
important thing but when I when I was
done with that one I create I finish
creating that I thought hey but how
about the cultural aspects that are also
inherited that are known in the genes
and then that became the topic Amalia so
to similarly similarly male give a Peace
Walker that the theme was deterrence but
after I was done with Peace Walker I
started thinking well but if there's the
terrace then why do we have all these
words and this all these words and all
over the globe and have thinking about
it were just like well maybe there's a
chain of revenge change of negativity
and overall revenge that is there which
became the theme of a year so five now
at that point when I have the team and I
think of how to relate that maybe
through gameplay story you play a story
whatever makes more sense to put
together to be able to communicate that
message now in terms of revenge
specifically as a theme what is it about
that topic that appeals to you as a
storyteller what does that let you do
with these with these characters that
you haven't done before
do you you whole pansy mascot oh grandma
zeroes I have to buy him a sec at all
user no cottony the mangy Fukushima
demon out you know do you none at all
talking snake that you are still not
seen ever
now come on now to stay Massa no karada
no naka still in there
cook sushi are discrete or more put it
in the gunk in a bucket Alaska you got
Itoh ya know they a P so corrupt if I
use that the you know and I'm deputy
come to you you can't forget that even
no matter Wizards could the master yeah
so no tomorrow ha issue mr. Hollander
don't you know so no Carlton wah yep
original game you know KK motto state
merit occur on there so no damn guide a
poppy soca attached to a snake pattern
you carry toe on acid ever unique
jeevanmukti much Ahmad picture under so
photo machine Kroger Naruto Takara ayat
a a gram buddy rose up Kyra homage to
buy stay so what the who position were
up Mortimer a tip phantom pain its
negative so you system all day from
Kairat cool much well this time I was
offering a being hard to put ribbons
through a game because you know well
people that played grand trios might
understand this but grand zeros snake
losses allies look the s historic
station destroyed lots of flames so
sleek has the big motivation for revenge
or how does that relate to the player
the player is some scratched they have
no they have nothing to do with this
right but for the people at least for
the people that played this walker what
I try to do is for people that play
peace workers spent several hundreds of
hours developing their motor base he put
a lot of time and effort into it and
then they going to burn zeros and this
is destroy so at that point I think that
the player is equally motivated as snake
is equally angry a snake and has the
same motivation for it remain so in
ground zeroes that's the reason that's
one of the reasons we put out this
separately I wanted people to have this
motivation for events at this point okay
well guys thank you very much for
joining me on the stage kojima-san
it's been a pleasure the new trailer
looks fantastic
new gameplay looks great I can't wait to
play fan or the
to pain I'm sure it's gonna be a lot of
fun and I wish you the best of luck
moving forward well thank you very much
it was wonderful guys that was it that
was our discussion with Hideo Kojima and
we're gonna jump to a quick commercial
break and we'll be back momentarily